[Music]
many of the most important questions in
public policy are quantitative by nature
in government organizations such as the
Joint Committee on taxation the
Congressional Budget Office spent tens
of millions of dollars developing
computational simulation models to
address just those questions as tax
reform heats up the JCT will predict the
revenue and macroeconomic effects of
competing proposals to guide Congress in
the public the CBO has had their share
of the limelight estimating the
insurance coverage and budgetary effects
of health care reform the problem is the
models these teams develop are not
available to the public this undermines
the free competition of ideas because
the public can't use the models to
develop creative new proposals it
undermines the predictive accuracy of
the models because their creators can't
participate fully in the scientific
community and it undermines trust in
government because how can the public
trust that which resides behind a
curtain Congress could mandate the
researchers in government share all of
their work openly and we would have
better tax policy better spending
policies and a healthier democracy to
learn more about open approaches to
policymaking and what is possible when
models are open
check out the open source policy Center
at ospc org also let us know what other
topics you'd like our scholars to cover
in 60 seconds and be sure to subscribe
for more videos and research from AEI